all right guys so let's start today i
have many many things to say
so i want to talk about amc i want to
talk about the spy i want to talk about
the crypto market guys this is all
related so let's start with amc so i'm
gonna do some technical analysis on amc
first then i'm gonna show you guys
something very very important that you
all need to be aware of regarding the
global market that is of course related
to amc and then i'm gonna quickly
analyze uh the crypto market bitcoin
because many of you are asking so let's
start with amc what do we have guys so
as you know in my last video i told you
that
uh since we broke out on the downside
from this uh triangle here this was not
looking good and usually the triangles
are continuation patterns all right so
most likely they are broken on the
upside but here unfortunately it got
broken on the downside so you can expect
a correction that can last one third to
one half of the triangle you know
sometimes more this is just the usual
thing so here the triangle lasts between
june and november so it's like seven
eight months so we can expect two three
month guys of correction so the
correction started in december so it's
one month and a half so we can expect
another month and a half so that's why i
told you something like this is likely
to happen the alternative scenario that
i'm talking about uh for some time guys
is that we break on the damp side and
then we go higher all right so i don't
know what will happen here what i know
is that when the support is tested many
times it gets weaker so it's been the
second time we're coming on 21 we had a
positive reaction again so let's see if
we get back to it again guys it might
break so just be prepared for that if it
breaks the level to buy where i will
personally add more shares is at 15. i
don't want to trade anything between
those two i'm hearing 16 as well
maybe all right 16 is the bottom of the
gap up that was here so it's a possible
level as well so what would uh actually
tell us what is going to happen here
guys we need to go on the global market
once again whenever the global market is
going lower everything is going lower
then we saw that we have this margin
calls happening
and i think we're gonna have it again
but lower so i would not expect some
margin calls coming right now if the
market is crashing if the market is
holding then amc can go to 37 you know
27 first then 37
to the eighth you know this area 36
the 200-day moving average would be
resistance as well 23 so all this area
would be a resistance area uh if we go
there we're probably gonna get rejected
at least the first time just like it
happens for support you first get
rejected you test it again then we can
go higher so i think we have some time
i'm of course bullish on the long run
because the movement is strong but what
i'm interested in is what is going to
happen on the global market so guys stay
with me this is very interesting i
shared this analysis on this code and i
want to share it with you guys here so
what is happening right now guys the
rates are gonna go higher this is what
scared the market at the beginning of
the year when the fed announced they're
gonna increase rates quicker than what
they announced the month before so
quicker slower we don't care the rates
are gonna go higher so this is an issue
for the market i mean it's not a big
issue but it's usually creating some
correction let me show you something
guys very interesting here the exact
same situation so i'm right now on the
spy chart guys and to look the orange
curve is the fed fence so they were at
zero let me show you the fed funds
quickly here guys so you can go on
trading view you can find the fed funds
so look at the fed funds guys okay i'm
going to go on the weekly time frame so
you can see the fed funds were at zero
between 209 and 215 then they went up
now zero again and they are gonna go
higher the rates are gonna take 75 basis
points this year so we're gonna have
something like this just like we had
here okay and the first rate hike is
going to happen in march so
we know that in three months we're going
to have the first rate hike what
happened here guys the first rate hike
happened in 2015 uh on november and look
at the global market here the spy guys
okay
so this is the first rate hike here guys
you can see the orange curve so when the
correction has started three months
before the first rate hike now is gonna
happen in march three months before jan
so we can expect if the same situation
occurs to have the correction doing an
abc pattern just like we had here guys
all right so we are in the same
situation so let's analyze the past and
just you know this is the best
information we can get on uh what is
going to happen next so we had an abc
correction with the a wave starting when
here in august 2 or 15 all right so
three months before guys the first rate
hike that is going to happen in march so
what else do we have we had here look we
are exactly in the s in this situation
the market was just pushing higher uh
very strongly and we had a bearish
divergence occurring here bearish
divergence guys you need to remember
that this is a sign of weakness the
market making higher highs but with a
decreasing momentum usually the volumes
are decreasing as well as you can see
here so keep this image in mind now i'm
going to show you what is happening okay
so let me get rid of the fat funds so
that we see more clearly this is some
stuff guys that i'm creating for my
course don't pay attention to that but
you remember what was happening we we
were having a market that is pushing
higher strongly the past few years
before the correction so now the the
rate hike is going to happen here so
this is going to be the b wave the a
wave should be here guys three months
before so i think we are starting the a
wave
and we are having here the market making
as you can see higher highs let me
unzoom like it was on that chart and you
can see here the macd going lower i was
on a daily time frame let's go back on a
daily time frame it's not so clear on
the daily time frame but it is still
here all right so we're having the macd
going lower okay depends where attack it
it's not that obvious on the daily
timeframe let's be honest we don't have
it we don't have the daily time frame
divergence maybe we have it on the rsi
it doesn't really matter what i mean is
that this market starts to be out of
steam but once again when we check what
happened in 2016 guys it can stay like
that for some time so there is of course
an alternative scenario i'm not saying
the correction is starting right now i'm
just saying that it might start right
now and we have all the signals that
tell that this correction might start
but we can also find support we have
some support at 460 push again higher
until maybe fab so maybe the alternative
scenario is that we have one more month
of uh bull market but then we're gonna
start the abc correction that should
start three months okay so keep this in
mind one more thing i want to show you
guys is the federal reserve balance
sheet so you guys know that they printed
a lot of money we are we are right now
at 9 000 billion us dollars printed
since they started this crazy printing
so
you can see
that here
it was going higher when we so i'm here
in 2015 2013 the market was pushing
higher and they were printing printing
printing all right and then here we had
the correction right in november 15 here
so whenever it was flat so right now
we're not flat yet we're gonna flatten
it in much so once again this is showing
you that maybe it's gonna take three
months maybe one month i don't know
maybe one week but sooner or later we're
gonna have this small correction about
15 probably that is gonna impact the
global market we probably gonna go to
420 on the spy then rebound so if this
happens now amc is going to go to 15
then rebound if this happens in one
month amc is probably going to go first
to 35 then i think correct with the
global market and then push higher all
right so this is my view and i just
explained why i believe this is what's
going to happen so if you want to
monitor the global market as well
because this is going to be related the
level on the spy is at 460 guys last
thing guys the crypto market many of you
are asking me so this is all gonna go
together okay crypto at 42 000. okay on
the weekly chat i don't see the leg that
went to 42 000 already a few months ago
but whatever so when you check bitcoin
guys we are correcting right now the
move that started in match 20 one two
three four five
exactly like we are on the spy all right
what what actually it's not exactly the
same on the spoi we're only in the third
wave of this strong move but we are
correcting what is happening since
october 20. so what is my view on
bitcoin we broke this wedge pattern let
me get rid of this first we broke this
wedge pattern guys that is forming the
fifth wave here at 55 000. whenever this
got broken i told you guys that i think
we're going to go to 37. and then we're
just moving lower all right so i had
some hope that we have a rebound a bit
earlier but we had a fake out i
personally lost a little bit of money in
this fake out i bought here the retest
and i start my position here right now
i'm a buyer at 37 000 as you guys know
because i'm sharing this with you on my
discord so 37 000 is the level i think
we might go why because once again when
we look on the weekly chart because this
is a long term correction that i mean
we're correcting a long-term move
usually so whenever the fifth wave is
finished we go to the top of the third
or bottom of the fourth the top of the
third is too high so the bottom of the
force makes sense all right so it would
be around 29 000 okay so this is the
bottom of the correction that we might
see but maybe not into a wave all right
right now we are just doing a wave
usually corrections happen doing an abc
so if this is only a wave happened in
five waves as you guys know so let's
zoom on the daily time frame and let me
show you why i'm gonna buy at 37 because
right now we are doing a a wave and i
think this is the scenario that might
happen so i measure one plus three
applied to the bottom of the force so
here the top it works on the downside or
on the upside and surprise look guys you
know the ratio sixty one point eight
percent one two one one two one point
six one eight okay those are the three
fib ratios we usually go whenever we
have one plus three so here the one two
one
two open six one eight is thirty seven
thousand five hundred all right and it's
i have some consolidation here i have
some consideration here so this is a
level that makes sense to me i think
this is where we're heading right now
then if everything rebounds the global
market amc this is all going to go
together we're going to do the b wave
that's probably going to go to 52 50 you
know something like this and then i
think the c wave might happen and this
is going to go together once again with
this correction that we expect to happen
in maybe one week and maybe three months
i'm not sure i'm monitoring the levels
and when this correction is going to
happen bitcoin is probably going to go
to 29 000 from there global market is
going to rebound amc is going to go
crazy and the bitcoin is going to
rebound as well this is my view guys
that's it for today tomorrow i'm going
to do triple q i'm going to do gme maybe
i'm gonna talk a bit about tesla lucid
as well he's doing some crazy moves guys
i mean not crazy but something is
happening there so i'm gonna talk about
that tomorrow i see you guys cheers